everyone's talking about inflation and
deflation these days including myself
and that's because it's important and in
order to really have an informed view on
it I think it's important to actually
look at how inflation is defined and
right here I actually took a screenshot
from my Bloomberg terminal of the basket
of goods that makes up the consumer
price index the index that sets
everything from the coupons on Treasury
inflation-protected securities this is
the index that dictates what Social
Security payments are going to how fast
they're going to grow I'm sure a bunch
of union agreements and pension
agreements are depend on the CPI so this
is this is the underlying basket of
because it really tells us what
inflation is and at a first level it's
just fun to look at because you can you
know you can kind of compare your own
household to what the government thinks
is a typical household for example the
government says that the typical house
bowl household spends fifteen point
seven percent of their disposable income
on you know and that's essentially the
income that you take home after you
paying taxes that they spend 15.7 on
food and beverages that seems reasonable
but it's even kind of more interesting
that they break it down I mean they get
very granular they try to figure out how
much do you spend on you know eggs and
fish and poultry and bakery products and
and that's good because let's say
everything else stays constant but the
price of eggs goes through the roof
because you know Atkins died the Atkins
diet becomes popular again then you can
actually make an informed decision as to
why inflation is going up or why or you
know whether inflation will go up going
forward so that's just interesting to
look at and if you look at the major
categories that food and beverages
housing and I'm going to come back to
housing because this is in general just
a very interesting area to focus on
because it makes such a big portion of
the CPI and it's been such a big portion
of the economic picture especially the
last ten years and and obviously it's
become a big problem with the it's
become a big factor in terms of what's
causing the financial crisis right now
but housing is about 43 percent of
disposable income a parallel three
percent transportation 15 percent this
includes things like southern you new
vehicles four percent used cars and
trucks and I think the way they
calculate
say oh you know what percentage of
Americans are driving you you new
vehicles versus you've used vehicles and
they put fuel in here and it's going to
you know the point that a lot of people
when I have this inflation deflation
argument they they make this argument
that China and India are going to
continue growing and because of that
commodities like oil and fuel will
continue to increase although that's you
know people were making that argument
more last summer but even now people are
making that argument but in in a
developed country you see that really
motor fuel even though it kind of hits
your pocketbook on the margin it isn't
that big a part of kind of your total
expenditure especially when you when you
compared to things like housing and if
you keep going down medical care six
percent and then recreation either they
break it down and you could look this up
I think the Bureau of Labor Statistics
has this broken down as well though it
was much easier to get it on the
Bloomberg terminal education you know an
average three percent obviously if
you're sending your kids to college
that's a much higher number but on
average if you take the average
household and finally other goods and
services tobacco etc etc so that one is
just interesting to look at so whenever
you have a discussion on the things that
might may or may not drive inflation
it's important to wait them by these
weightings that the CPI gives them to
actually figure out what the actual
impact on on how we measure inflation
really will be and with that said if you
think about it the really the biggest
portion of this is the housing piece
right housing and and I think that's
fair housing is a large percentage of
most people's disposable income
especially in a Western society you can
imagine if you live in a third world
country and you're barely getting by
food might be a huge part of your
expenditure and you know maybe rivaling
housing if you've kind of you know if
you've just kind of built a house
someplace but in a developed society
housing is a huge percentage of it and I
want to focus on one thing and this is a
lot of people have talked about this and
actually mich once again from global
economic analysis he he really
encouraged me to highlight this
so within housing obviously some people
rent some people buy and so they give a
6% weighting of the whole basket to rent
and then they give a 20 roughly 24 25
and waiting to something that they call
owners equivalent of rent of primary
residence so this is essentially their
attempt to measure how much it cost to
live for people who own houses but
what's interesting and you probably have
caught on to it is that they use the
word owners equivalent rent so what they
do and this is the current methodology
they don't say how much is your mortgage
they don't say how much does it cost you
to you know buy that house and amortize
it over the life of you know the the
reasonable life of the house they
actually just say how much would it cost
to rent that house and they've they've
kept waffling back and forth between
sometimes they they just look for
equivalent houses and they say well how
much would that cost to rent at one
point they're actually surveying people
and said they would ask them how much
would it cost to rent your house which
is probably even a worse number but the
bottom line is they're not factoring in
actual mortgages and you can even see it
on the waiting right you know right when
I looked at these numbers I was like
well you know roughly 66 percent of
people owned houses how come this number
isn't 66 percent relative to this number
right it's closer to 80 percent it's
like oh we know that's fair because more
people actually live in homes right you
could say that 66 percent of of overall
households own but in general homes are
bigger there might be more people in it
so you could either think of it on kind
of a person basis or maybe on a square
footage basis it makes a little bit more
sense to wait houses higher but what's
interesting here is that this number
especially if you if you know if you add
these two housing in general it's about
30 percent it's about 30 percent of
disposable income and traditionally that
was you know kind of the rule that a a
bank would use to decide whether you can
afford a house in Muniz shouldn't be
more than a third of your disposable
income or at least a mortgage payment
shouldn't be more than third but we know
especially over this last this last real
estate bubble that that has become a
much much larger percentage of people's
actual disposable income so you know you
wonder well why is this weighting only
thirty thirty percent of the Spoils
income well that's because they use
owner owner
the equivalent rent they didn't actually
say what people's mortgage payments are
so even though mortgage payments might
be going through the roof even though
the price of a house might be going
through a roof it does not get reflected
in the in the CPI number as of the early
80s and actually go to the this is
straight from the Bureau of Labor
Statistics website and they wrote and
they actually using doublespeak here I
just copied and pasted straight from
their website until the early 1980s the
CPI used what is called the asset price
method to measure the change in the cost
of owner-occupied housing that makes
sense and I'm not sure what they did
they just looked at how much houses cost
this year relative to last year and they
and then they put that into the
weighting or they determine the
weighting based on people's average
mortgage but in general that's a good
way to measure it right either with your
mortgage payment or how much houses cost
and they said the asset price method
treats the purchase of an asset such as
a house as it does the purchase of any
consumer good fair enough because the
asset price method can lead to
inappropriate results and this this is
the key line because the asset price
method can lead to inappropriate results
for goods that are purchased largely for
investment reasons I agree with that if
something is per is purchased largely
for investment reasons if I'm purchasing
gold maybe that shouldn't be included in
the CPI because it's largely for
investment reasons or for stocks but
then they use this kind of completely
disjoint logic and they say you know
because asset price method can lead to
inappropriate results for goods that are
purchased largely for investment reason
the CPI implemented the rental
equivalents approach to measuring the
price change for owner occupied housing
that's to me that makes no sense right
owner occupied because I mean owner
occupied is not purchased for investment
raising that I would I would that's a
fair enough argument if you're doing it
for rentals if you're doing it for
vacation homes but for actual owner
occupied housing this sentence makes no
sense based on their own rationale
there's no reason to transfer to this
this rental equivalent approach but the
whole reason why I'm you know I'm going
here is because because they've they've
in ninth in the early 80s I think 1983
or
say it right here in January 1983
because they switched over to this this
kind of inflation that we've seen in the
price of houses especially the the real
estate bubble we've seen the last 10
years in no way got incorporated into
the inflation numbers so it essentially
understated them and you can see that
here this is well two things not only
did it understate it but it probably
understated the weighting itself and
mish he's made he's had a couple of
posts about this that you know you
really should use something like the
case-shiller index on this line right
here instead of doing this owner
equivalent but I'd argue one step
further not only should you use
something like the case-shiller index
but to actually gauge this weighting you
should actually survey people and just
say what percentage of your disposable
income is dedicated to your mortgage and
other things related to owning a house
and especially over the last seven years
I would guess and I'm almost sure about
this that it would be much larger than
30 percent of your disposable income so
not only was this number being
understated or the growth in that number
because it didn't incorporate the
increase in housing prices but this
weighting itself was understated and
just to get a sense of how much this is
the Case Shiller index and you could
look up the Case Shiller index but in my
opinion is the best index for actual
increases or decreases in the price of
homes you see from 2001 to 2006 roughly
houses were increasing by 10 to 15% a
year so if you use that instead of the
rental equivalents and over the same
timeframe I don't have a chart for rent
but rent was not increasing it anywhere
near this pace if anything people were
leaving apartments to buy houses so rent
was actually staying pretty stable but
10 to 15 percent this is year-over-year
growth this is what this chart is so 10
to 15% if you wait that at 30 percent of
people's of the of the CPI basket then
really the the reported inflation number
was being understated by three to five
percent a year and I had argued that
that weighting should have been this
weighting should have grown over that
time period because people were spending
more and more of their disposable income
on their mortgage payments so really it
was probably understating it by more
that this weighting should have been
more like 40 percent and you could have
said they were understating it by 4%
four to six percent and if you look here
you know this is the actual reported CPI
numbers what I'm saying is over that
time frame the real inflation numbers
should have been up here and then now
that we have actual deflation and home
prices this is zero so now the most
recent case Shiller numbers say that
housing has depreciated by twenty
percent we're essentially understating
the the deflation now so although you
know right now the CPI has a said kind
of the zero mark if you actually
incorporated the real prices of homes
and you didn't use rents as a proxy for
it you would actually get a much more
negative number here and Mitch actually
did that on his blog and if you actually
want to read his blog which I highly
recommend
do a Google search for mish Mis H and
this is directly from his blog so after
give him credit for that and what he did
here is he actually charted the actual
inflation numbers that's reported that's
in blue and then on top of that he he
put what he calls the case-shiller CPI
index and that's in red and you see here
or especially over the housing book this
is what we got this is the these are the
inflation numbers we got from the
government which put things you know
they peaked out in the four or five
percent range which isn't low by any
stretch of the imagination and that's
probably why the Fed started increasing
interest rates right around here right
but you know arguably at the worst
possible time but if you look at the the
CS CPI or the Case Shiller CPI you could
almost say that the real inflation was
actually peaked out let's see that
number in the eight percent range back
here and you could argue that if this
was the actual number that the Fed was
using it would have actually been a much
better policy tool because they would
have seen the inflation pop up back here
in January of three and they would have
known that they were keeping their
monetary policy too loose back here and
they could have avoided this whip song
that they did in in in 2007 and 2008 and
I'd argue even further that even this
number is understating the reality
because back here as a percentage of the
actual CPI basket he just took that the
CPI numbers and replaced the
year-over-year change essentially into
the same weighting as the current CPI
numbers but if you actually weighted it
based on the act
amount of disposable income people were
spending on their mortgages I would
guess it would look something more like
this
and you would have seen actual inflation
peak out here probably in the 10 or 11
percent range and you know there's a lot
of I guess the social commentary about
this why they do it one you know one
argument is is that a lot of the
governments or even corporate
liabilities liabilities are indexed to
inflation right you have an inflation
index and on the other hand the the sale
of homes
it essentially transfers wealth from one
generation to another especially when
you have a huge increase in that in the
the price of homes so by you know if you
if they did this on purpose and I'm
guessing that they did what it allows
something it allows housing prices to
increase dramatically and when housing
prices increase dramatically it
essentially allows it transfers wealth
from the new buyer generation to the
retiree generation so it helps subsidize
the retirees and at the same time by
taking it out of the actual CPI index it
keeps the government and actually a lot
of other corporate liabilities low
because now Social Security it's indexed
to inflate index to the CPI number so if
you if the CPI numbers are not
incorporating or you know are not
raising up here you don't have to
increase people's Social Security
payments and you kind of get to you know
project this farsh to people that you
say Oh an inflation adjusted terms you
are doing better than your parents
generation did oh but by the way you can
afford one-third the house now and you
know to some degree that's been
propagated to large it's you know
obviously all falling apart now but the
the big takeaway from this if I had to
give you just one is that the CPI index
is a government created tool it's based
on a survey and not only has it not been
the same survey but it's actively
changed over the years as changed in
ways that significantly impact the
actual numbers that are reported and to
some degree play into what I think
government wants people to believe
anyway see in the next video